are you ready to start preparing for the
professional security engineer
certification exam well in this course
you will assess your exam Readiness and
form a personalized workbook that will
guide you for your certification Journey
hi I'm Sean a technical curriculum
developer at Google cloud and I'll
introduce you to the professional
security engineer certification and how
to prepare for it now this content is
designed for experienced security
Engineers that are ready to become
Google Cloud certified
before taking this course you should
have experienced designing and managing
Security Solutions in Google Cloud
in this course you'll be exposed to and
engage with exam topics through a series
of lectures and quizzes
upon completion of this course you'll
understand the domains covered on the
exam and you'll be able to identify gaps
in your Knowledge and Skills for each
domain
enroll in this course to prepare to
become a certified Google Cloud security
engineer